we are playing the game two truths and a  lie where i have to figure out which  person is not telling the truth my worst  first date we went to a smoothie bar at  9 30 in the morning on a saturday and he  talked the entire time and tried to  pitch me his business idea to bring to  buzzfeed my first date horror story is  that during casual conversation with my  date height came up i think i was saying  something like oh i wish i was taller  you know for models usually like 5 11  plus and he said well it could be worse  you could be a [ __ ] haha that would  suck i mean what if you like your sister  was a [ __ ] or something and then  you're like well really right you never  know who's i mentioned that like oh you  know i have family that are southern  he's like we don't have cousins that are  married do you and i'm like  my first state horror story is that i  accidentally took an edible prior to the  first date thinking it was just a cookie  and  threw up